pour échapper à une situation économique
devenue insoutenable à lima des
centaines de paires vient se lance sur
les routes pour rejoindre leur région
d'origine
depuis le début de confinement il ya
plus d'un mois ces migrants internes
sont sans emploi sans être public et
pour certains sans logement des familles
entières qui n'ont d'autre choix que de
rentrer dans leur ville natale
nous envoyons les photos au gouvernement
régional peut montrer la situation et
nous ne savons toujours rien nous ne
savons pas quelles solutions les
autorités vont lui proposer
on espère que des bus sont venir nous
récupérer voilà ce qu'on veut
le commandant de la police de lima nous
a donné un droit de passage car il n'y a
sûrement pas de solution ils ont fait
passer le mot et nous marchons vers
notre destination
émue la bamba la jungle une route semée
d'embûches effets personnels sur le dos
et péruviens sont bloqués depuis
plusieurs jours par un barrage des
forces de l'ordre sur l'autoroute
principale de lima en attendant le
déblocage de la situation les migrants
reçoivent nourriture et eau prendre des
forces pour un trajet qui s'annonce très
très long pour ces centaines de paires
vient originaire de la région de san
martin soit au moins dix jours à pied
depuis la capitale
et si la chance leur sourit 18h15